-President Trump
has spent the week
defending himself from
accusations of Russian collusion
and defending
his Supreme Court nominee
from accusations
of sexual assault.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
During the campaign,
Trump borrowed from years
of GOP rhetoric
and referred to himself
as the "law and order"
candidate.
Trump used the phrase
"law and order"
more often than my cable guide.
[ Laughter ]
He insisted that the law should
apply equally to everyone,
and by "everyone,"
he meant immigrants,
people of color,
and Hillary Clinton.
-What makes us exceptional
is that we are a nation of laws
and that we are all equal
under those laws.
Hillary's corruption
shreds the principle
of which our nation was founded.
We either have a country
or we don't.
We're a country of laws.
We either have a border
or we don't.
-"We either have a border
or we don't."
Trump's brain
is only capable of lies
and super, super obvious truths.
[ Laughter ]
After all,
this is the same brain
that just the other day
called Hurricane Florence
"one of the wettest
we've ever seen
from the standpoint of water."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh!
Oh, from
the standpoint of water.
I'm so glad you clarified.
[ Light laughter ]
Trump's like a college freshman
trying to write
a five-page essay for a class
he never attended.
"In this essay, I will show that
water has a high wetness level,
and that the general
wetness of water, which is,
as it relates to being water,
very wet
from a water standpoint."
"Donald, the margins
on this paper are 3 1/2 inches."
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you go.
You heard Trump.
You heard him.
We are a country of laws.
Like, for example,
election laws.
And yet Trump
has spent the week insisting
that the Russia probe
is illegitimate.
He took the unprecedented step
of declassifying documents
from the investigation
in an attempt to undermine it,
and in an interview
with "The Hill,"
he even blamed Attorney General
Jeff Sessions, saying,
"I don't have
an Attorney General.
It's very sad."
Oh, my God.
He's like a wounded mother
who just found weed
in her son's sock drawer.
[ Laughter ]
"Get out of my house!"
"But I'm your son!"
"I don't have a son."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And yet --
And yet while Trump undermines
the Russia investigation,
he also wants to make it
seem like
he's been tough on Russia,
as he did during
a press conference on Tuesday
where he claimed he was
countering Russian aggression
with force.
-I think that Russia
has acted aggressively.
They respect force.
They respect strength,
as anyone does.
And we have the greatest
strength in the world.
Especially now.
We were being depleted
under the last administration.
We had planes
that were old and tired
and didn't fly in some cases.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
The planes wouldn't fly
because they were tired.
[ Laughter ]
It's official --
Trump thinks in cartoons.
In his mind, the planes fly by
literally flapping their wings,
and they have faces
like Thomas the Tank Engine.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, fella.
And yet every day, the Russia
probe gets worse for Trump.
Last week, his ex-campaign
chairman Paul Manafort
flipped on him,
and late today we found out
that his long-time personal
lawyer and fixer, Michael Cohen,
met with investigators, too.
-President Trump's former
personal attorney Michael Cohen
has been interviewed
multiple times
by Special Counsel
Robert Mueller's team
over the past few weeks,
according to ABC News.
The interviews
have lasted for hours
and been focused
on Trump's dealings with Russia
and any possible conspiracy
between the Trump campaign
and Moscow.
-Damn, I'm not saying
Trump is scared right now,
but when he heard that,
his pants were
the wettest we've ever seen...
[ Laughter ]
...from the standpoint of water.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, again, this is a man
who said we're a nation of laws.
If he's not concerned
with breaking election law,
then how about laws
against sexual assault?
What did Trump have to say
when he was asked about
the allegations
against his Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh?
Probably something like,
"We're a nation of laws,
and justice must be served."
Let me lean on my fists
and watch.
-I feel so badly for him
that he's going through this,
to be honest with you.
I feel so badly for him.
This is not a man
that deserves this.
Really, they're hurting
somebody's life very badly.
And it's very unfair,
I think, to --
As you know, Justice Kavanaugh's
been treated very, very tough.
And his family, I think,
it's a very unfair thing
what's going on.
He is such an outstanding man.
Very hard for me to imagine
that anything happened.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Now...
Now, Trump has said --
Trump has said he wants to hear
from Kavanaugh's accuser,
Dr. Christine Blasey Ford.
But he also said Democrats
were only coming forward
with these allegations now
for political reasons.
They make a lot of stuff?
If I started listing
all the stuff you've made up,
I'd still be here tomorrow
during "Days of Our Lives."
[ Laughter ]
Trump and Senate Republicans
are trying to sound like
they're being fair-minded,
but in reality,
it's clear they have no interest
in getting to the bottom
of what happened.
One way they could do that
is by asking the FBI
to reopen their
background check on Kavanaugh,
something the FBI
does all the time.
But Trump has tried
to make it sound like
the FBI
doesn't want to get involved.
-What would be the problem
with the FBI
reopening
their background investigation
into Judge Kavanaugh?
Would you support such a thing?
-It wouldn't bother me,
other than the FBI, John,
said that they
really don't do that.
That's not what they do.
-I don't think the FBI
really should be involved
because they don't want
to be involved.
If they wanted to be,
I would certainly do that.
But as you know, they say
this is not really their thing.
-It's not their thing?
They're the
Federal Bureau of investigation.
"Investigation"
is in the damn name.
That's like saying
you don't think Taco Bell
is interested in making tacos.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this will shock you --
it turns out Trump is lying.
Bloomberg News
reported Wednesday that...
Of course they can!
And Trump knows that.
He wakes up
at 5:00 a.m. every morning
and scream tweets in all caps
about how the FBI
should be investigating
"Crooked Hillary"
or the "Dirty Dossier"
or why Rudy Giuliani's eyes
are always
trying to jump out of his head.
[ Laughter ]
Republicans
clearly have no desire
to get to the bottom
of what happened.
All they care about is getting
a man accused of sexual assault
on the Supreme Court so
he can implement their agenda.
If you have
any doubt about that,
watch this exchange with
Louisiana Senator John Kennedy.
A CNN anchor tries
to explain to Kennedy calmly
the details of Ford's story,
but Kennedy won't have it.
-You've got to have
some evidence, some facts.
-Okay. So, here's what we do --
here's what we do have.
-But, can I just --
-Because --
-Poppy, let me finish.
-I heard your three --
I heard your three points,
and the third one is --
-Poppy, you're better than this.
Let me finish my answer.
You're better than this.
-Your third point is salient,
and you said
there have to be some facts,
and I just want
to note for our viewers
the facts that
"The Washington Post" reported,
which includes...
-Okay, let me -- let me --
-...therapist's notes
from 2012...
-Right.
-...which include
a polygraph test.
Yes?
-Can I talk now?
-Yes.
-Oh, okay.
I need to see the facts.
[ Laughter ]
-You're seeing them!
She's literally explaining them
to your face.
"I need to see the facts."
"Okay.
Here are the facts."
"Stop interrupting me with facts
when I'm in the middle
of demanding facts!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"This is my
fact-demanding time!"
Republicans are making it
clear as possible
that they
aren't actually interested
in hearing the truth about
what Brett Kavanaugh did,
which is infuriating,
since Trump and Republicans
spent the
entire campaign saying,
"We're a nation of laws."
Although, in fairness,
honesty is...
-Not really their thing.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]